[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es etwas
traditionell arabisches und zwar machen
wir magna kluge heißt nämlich so viel
wie umgedreht denn alles was in unserem
kopf zu bereiten das drehen wir dann am
ende um und dann haben wir dieses
leckere gericht
mit circa sechs personen benötigen wir
viel hähnchenschenkel ca 2 liter
leitungswasser etwas rapsöl gestiftete
möhren kartoffeln die werden gleich noch
in scheiben geschnitten klon kuh
geschälte mandeln und angeboten
benötigen bio paprika flocken pfeffer
salz und zimt und außerdem 450 gramm
reis zuerst wird das öl in einer pfanne
erhitzt dass die viel kaffee bis fünf
esslöffel dann geben wir die
hähnchenschenkel hinein und die werden
von allen seiten frustig angebraten
vorher das ganze aber mit unseren
gewürzen ich hab das einfach alles
vermischt und auf die hähnchenschenkel
gegeben
dieser stelle habe ich gemerkt dass mein
topf etwas zu klein ist sorgt auf jeden
fall für einen ausreichend großen topf
denn wir müssen das ganze jahr später
noch im wasser kochen lassen einen
größeren topf werden sie also schön
angebraten von allen seiten und wenn sie
dann knusprig sind dann gehen wir auch
schon das wasser mit hinzu und lassen
das ganze einmal aufkochen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt kommt da noch der deckel drauf und
das ganze kostet aus meiner anderen
herdplatte die classe 45 minuten lang
der zwischenzeit frittieren wir schon
mal das gemüse wenn ihr die luftbläschen
seht auf einem holzstiel dann ist das öl
soweit heiß genug und wir können schon
mal anfangen den so cool darin zu
krepieren nach ungefähr fünf minuten
sind wir dann auch schön goldbraun und
sie können sie auf küchenpapier
abtropfen lassen
genau so mache ich dann weiter mit dem
hören die lasse ich auf zirka vier bis
fünf minuten lang frittieren und nehmen
sie dann heraus und wir auf küchenpapier
abtropfen zu lassen
[Musik]
zu guter letzt noch die entscheiden
geschnittenen kartoffeln wenn wir auch
schön goldbraun sind dann könnte sie
aussehen und das gemüse ist soweit
vorbereitet
[Musik]
45 minuten sind um und die
hähnchenschenkel sind gar sie mich jetzt
raus und das wasser das trieb die auf
keinen fall wegschütten das benötige
noch ich werde das nur einmal kurz durch
ein sieb geben
jetzt benötigen wir einen richtig großen
und vor allem hohen topf und da kommen
zuallererst die gestifteten höheren
hinein ganze rufe ich mit meinen händen
die hähnchenschenkel und gebe sie
darüber
[Musik]
darauf kommen dann die frittierten
kartoffeln und zu guter letzt noch der
blumenkohl den reifen mit sie vorher
bitte unbedingt unter fließendem wasser
abspülen damit die ganze stärke heraus
gewaschen wird und er kommt jetzt auch
noch in den top der übrig gebliebene
hühner droht er sollte etwas salzig
schmecken den geben wird über den reis
und der reis sollte komplett mit dem
hühnersuppe bedeckt sein und vatis nicht
ganz ausreicht liegt ruhig noch ein
bisschen wasser mit hinzu nachdem es
dann einmal auf gekocht wurde muß es bei
geschlossenem deckel und niedriger hitze
ca 35 minuten lang garen für den salat
habe ich mir hier schon vorbereitet
wurden tomaten und rote titeln außerdem
ein kopfsalat und für das dressing
benötigen wie rapsöl den saft einer
halben zitrone und einen halben
teelöffel salz das gemüse wird jetzt so
klein wie möglich geschnitten ich nehme
für so große mengen immer am liebsten
das macht wirklich alles super klein und
auch gleich groß aber wenn ihr sollt ich
habe macht es einfach mit einem messer
das ist auch kein problem
die kommen dann auch zum eisbergsalat
ihn habe ich vorher schon in kleine
stücke geschnitten
zugleich macht er es auch mit den
tomaten die kommen dann auch noch mit
hinzu und dann fehlt nur noch das
pressing für das pressing gebe ich zu
den vier esslöffel rapsöl noch wald und
den saft der zitrone und dann vermisse
ich das alles miteinander nach pk 35
minuten garzeit ist man reis durch und
das heißt dass man kluge ist fertig ich
drücke den rhein aber jetzt nochmal an
den boden amt damit es beim umdrehen
auch schön festhält zum umdrehen meines
kopfes benutze ich übrigens für ein
großes silbernes tablett da welches dort
auch gleich drauf verlieren und zupft am
besten noch ein paar mal drauf lasst es
fünf minuten lang stehen und dann könnt
ihr den top auch anheben
jetzt habe ich mir nur noch die möhren
kurs zurecht gelegt weil sie sich ein
bisschen verschoben haben und was ich
auch noch getan habe das empfehle ich
euch auch sehr die mandeln einmal in
butter anbraten dann werden sie so
frauen und schmecken sie unglaublich
lecker vom pier habe ich noch darüber
gegeben und was jetzt noch fehlt ist nur
noch der salat
[Musik]
somit ist unser max luger auch schon
fertig und sofort sehr wir bereit und
das ist so ein alles in allem gerecht
denn ihr habt ja beilage und hauptspeise
ihr preis fleisch gemüse und salat also
kein stress ihn müssten nichts mehr dazu
servieren paar kluge wird übrigens aus
dem silbernen tablett heraus gegessen
also ihr müsst keine extra zähler dazu
reichen liegt einfach löffel hin so wie
ich es getan habe und dann kann sich
auch schon jeder bedienen
vielen dank dass ihr bis zum ende dabei
geblieben seid und wenn ihr nicht
verpassen möchte dann lass mir doch
gerne ein abo da bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]